were Ukraine's president received a
standing ovation at the European
Parliament in an address to MPS of a lot
of mirzalinski thanked EU leaders for
their support in the war against Russia
zielinski said Ukraine is not only
fighting for its own Survival but for
the survival of Europe
I think all of you who helped Ukraine
with important supplies weapons
ammunition equipment and fuel thousands
of items without which we wouldn't be
able to endure this Total War I thank
you ladies and gentlemen
which James Bays joins us live from
inside the European Parliament in
Brussels and James it was a clearly a
powerful and emotive speech from
zelenski do you think it will have the
desired effect
well certainly there was standing
ovations from the members of the
European Parliament as the Ukrainian
leader spoke in the European Parliament
uh it was the message very much a thank
you message but added into the thank you
message which we've also heard earlier
in his visits in London and Paris is
thank you for what you've done so far
but my country needs more from you he
wasn't specific here in this speech in
the way he has been in London 24 hours
ago about exactly what those needs are
but we know that he wants fighter jets
we know he wants long-range missiles in
addition to what's already been
delivered and been promised and of
course the most important thing that's
been promised in recent weeks is those
main battle tanks that was controversial
Germany had to be won over but that is
something now that is expected to be
delivered in the coming months in the
coming year the other thing of course
that the ukrainians want long term is a
different relation relationship with the
European Union because long term they
want to be a member of the European
Union Mr lazelenski said this is our
Europe these are our roots and he said
with certainty uh when he said the next
line uh Ukraine will be a member of the
European uh Union he's left the European
Parliament now and a short time ago very
short distance away also in the center
of Brussels in the EU area of Brussels
he's arrived at the European Council the
European Council is the body that exists
when the leaders of the European nations
meet all 27 leaders were there on a
Podium as president zielinski arrived
they all applauded him they've now
headed off for a private meeting and I
think that's where the serious business
will be done and some of those please
from president zielinski for more help
help I think there he's going to go into
much more detail of what he wants okay
thank you for that update that's James
Bay for us in Brussels